There is only one Billionaires' Row in the world,...
...and it's in New York City...
...and it's on 57th Street, and it's all for profit.
It is a safety deposit in the sky for some of the richest people in the world.
Some of the buildings on Billionaires' Row are quite beautiful and amazing constructs.
But we're at a moment in society...
...where there's a widespread great reckoning with the abuses of power...
...and the concentrations of wealth.
I hope that in ten years time,...
...we look back at Billionaire's Row as a phenomenal mistake...
...and a dozen missed opportunities.
And the most important thing that I hope comes out of Billionaires' Row...
...is that the city changes the way that it taxes property,...
...changes the way that it does incentive zoning...
...to actually get the most, and a fair distribution of payments.